anybody making over 250,000 no she's  going to pay you god it's time to be  patriotic okay time to jump in time to  be part of the deal time to help get  America out of the rut speaking  personally I think know how to very rich  people out there who we can tax did you  use software to prepare your 2001 and  2000 do tax return I use TurboTax repair  pictures and film ever change you're the  chairman of the House Ways and Means  Committee the rights all the tax law how  can you have problems paying your taxes  just because a report in the new of  times as the problem with me does it  mean that the Congress in the country  has a problem and I think when we spread  the wealth around its River  talk about that is my original ish I  knew it wasn't complete people earning  over 250 thousand dollars will have a  tax increase and what can I say that  then what can you say to them thank you  it's time to be patriotic that's what  you say to them